[Music]
that's what it says
joe rogan is arguably
probably the most if not one of the most
listened to podcasters
he built that audience
very much over time very much
organically through
youtube
through these very extensive very long
interviews
i think people you know really
gravitated toward his interviewing style
and so over time he's he's become a
really influential figure in this space
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's a misinformation challenge tied
to joe rogan in particular but there's
also a broader misinformation problem i
think in this entire ecosystem it is a
lot more challenging simply because it
is so decentralized and there isn't
really
one platform um there isn't really one
player involved who can take the lead in
moderating it's very decentralized
[Music]
they claim that they've taken down
tens of thousands of episodes promoting
cloven misinformation but it's unclear
what those episodes did for example
or where those episodes were who who who
created them what those episodes were
why they were taken down um and why
rogan's episodes don't
necessarily fall into that category
[Music]
you